un camion qui vient à la propre or pour
y prendre le train la scène est insolite
elle va devenir habituelles matin et
soir des remorques seront chargés ici
direction calais où le boulou à la
frontière espagnole
un nouveau service proposé aux
entreprises de la région
ce train effectivement est ouvert à
l'ensemble des transporteurs du bassin
d'emploi voire même ailleurs et il
permet justement de diversifier notre
offre d'avoir plus de flexibilité
d'avoir une meilleure attractivité
parmi les premiers à opter pour le
ferroutage au départ de mâcon le groupe
à l'aîné qui n'a pas hésité à adapter
une partie de sa flotte
on a investi donc massivement dans des
fameuses remorque p400 nous sommes la
deuxième société en france à avoir
massivement investi dans ce type
d'équipement +2 sans équipement à ce
jour et c'est un équipement qui est qui
va nous permettre d'aller également sur
les voies ferroviaires internationales
dire qu'on va pouvoir à terme déplacer
nos remorques sur les pays d'europe
centrale ou à la péninsule ibérique en
traversant les frontières à mâcon les
opérateurs tablent sur le transport de
10000 remorque par an dans un premier
temps mais tous espèrent une montée en
charge rapide de l'activité
il ya une vraie accélération il ya une
reprise de conscience il ya des vraies
contraintes à la route la pénurie de
conducteurs et les problèmes de
variation importante du cours du pétrole
qui font honte lectrices ont compliqué à
gérer donc à une vraie demande
et puis de l'autre côté elle ferroviaire
qui s'adaptent mieux qu'ils sont nés des
services qui sont plus en rapport avec
le besoin les routiers en utilisant le
rail les transporteurs réduisent aussi
leurs émissions de co2 de 80%
un autre argument aujourd'hui pour leur
faire aimer le train